So
at this point, I think I have to say something
about the situation with Julian Maxwell in
particular, because this came up at Donald
Trump's Tuesday Corona virus press briefing.
And Trump, again, was just caught in another
apparent lie to the point where I'm increasingly
convinced that Trump is scared of what G.
Lane Maxwell may reveal.
Anthony Scaramouch.
He believes that that's exactly what's going
on.
And so we're going to go through it.
So just to reset.
Jeffrey Epstein was arrested and charged with
multiple counts of sex trafficking and assaulting
young girls.
This this video will now be monetized because
I mentioned his name, unfortunately.
But we've got to talk about this.
This has been known for a long time.
There's documentaries now about Jeffrey Epstein.
It's been widely explored, documented.
He was ultimately found dead in his jail cell
of a reported suicide.
His girlfriend may be ex girlfriend, whatever
alleged groomer and trafficker of women and
girls.
Jillian Maxwell, who was out of the public
eye for some time but has since been arrested
a few weeks ago.
Now, there are widespread pictures from the
last 20 plus years and videos of Donald Trump,
together with Jeffrey Epstein, Angie Lane
Maxwell, including with Melania Trump without
Melania Trump over the years.
There is video we once looked at of Trump
and Eppstein at a party I believe it was in
the late 90s. Trump and Epstein together,
sort of watching and discussing different
young women who were dancing in front of them
might have been the early 2000s.
The point is wide spread connections between
Trump and Epstein.
Now, Donald Trump was asked about Maxwell
on Tuesday and Trump wished her well.
Which is a really weird thing to say about
an alleged sex trafficker, given the number
of alleged victims.
But Trump also mentioned something about Prince
Andrew, which you may find interesting.
So let's take a look at that clip.
Just Wayne Maxwell is in prison.
And so a lot of people want to know she's
going to turn in powerful people.
He talked in the past about Santorum and criticized
Bill Clinton's behavior.
I'm wondering, how do you feel that she's
to turn in powerful men?
How do you see that working out?
I don't know.
I haven't really been following it too much.
I just wish her well, frankly.
I've met her numerous times over the years,
especially since I lived in Palm Beach, and
I guess they lived in Palm Beach.
But I wish her well, whatever it is.
I don't know the situation with Prince Andrew.
I just don't know.
Not aware of it.
So a lot of people are focusing on Trump saying
he wishes her well, arguably a wild thing
to say, given that she, Lane Maxwell, is accused
of grooming and trafficking in young girls
and has left so many alleged victims in her
wake.
But the thing about and we're going to talk
about wishing her well in a moment.
But the thing about Prince Andrew is particularly
interesting, because once again, Trump claims
total ignorance.
Prince Andrew and Epstein, I don't know anything
about that.
But we have video.
Check out this video from February of 2015.
This is when Donald Trump was getting ready
to run for president in this clip.
He says he's about 80 percent certain he's
going to run for president.
And it sure seemed like Trump knew a lot about
Jeffrey Epstein and Prince Andrew in this
clip.
Take a look.
You raised the question of Jeffrey Epstein
in your remarks about there.
Q And is that a problem?
I don't think I don't know.
But that island was really a cesspool.
There's no question about it.
Just ask Prince Andrew.
He'll tell you about it.
The island was an absolute cesspool.
So he's our friend.
He's been there for many times.
Well, I can't say friends, but I know friendly.
You know them.
They play at my clubs, a lot of clubs and
everybody likes to play.
Same saying Trump knows about the island.
And he says Prince Andrew specifically is
the guy you want to talk to.
And he even kind of gives a weird kind of
knowing look to one of the people sitting
at that desk on camera.
There's Prince Andrew can tell you about it.
So clearly, in 2015, Trump did think and know
about a connection between Epstein and Prince
Andrew.
So there's a couple of possibilities here.
And of course, none of them are good.
One is Trump is lying now.
Trump lies all the time.
This is what a lot of people suspect.
And the idea is Trump has been intimately
involved with Jeffrey Epstein and he knows
all about Prince Andrew.
And now he's lying and saying, I don't know
anything about Prince Andrew.
But remember, there's a 13 year old girl,
then 13 year old girl, who at one point accused
Trump and Epstein of raping her in Epstein's
Manhattan condo.
That suit was since dropped.
The other possibility is, again, one of Trump's
cognitive decline.
And you might have noticed that in the 2015
clip I played for you.
Trump is obviously more articulate, more together
than he is now.
It's possible Trump has just lost all memory
and he has no recollection of knowing about
the Eppstein Prince Andrew connection.
There have been allegations that say Trump
regularly forgets things that happened five
days ago, forgets things all the time.
So either Trump is a liar and he knows everything
that there is to know or much of what there
is to know about Prince Andrew and.
Or he's lost his memory.
Neither inspires a lot of confidence.
Now, I want to get to one other component
of this, and that's what I mean to talk about
next.
And that's the idea that when Trump says I
wish her well about she Lane Maxwell.
You hear that?
I hear that.
It sounds weird.
Why would he wish?
Well, to an alleged child sex trafficker,
Anthony Scaramouch, he says that's code from
Trump Tucci Lane Maxwell to shut up and not
say a word about Donald Trump.
So let's talk about that next.